del auto y luego utilizaron herramientas sofisticadas
de ingeniería inversa
para saber lo que hacía el software,
encontraron sus vulnerabilidades,
y crearon mecanismos para atacarlas.
De hecho, realizaron el ataque en la vida real.
Compraron dos autos —me imagino
que tienen un mejor presupuesto que yo—.
El primer modelo era para comprobar lo que sucedería
si un atacante tuviera acceso
a la red interna del auto.
Bien, piensa en ello como si alguien accede a tu coche,
lo utiliza para hacer tonterías por ahí y luego lo abandona,
y ahora, ¿en qué problema te han metido?
El otro modelo es uno en el cual te contactan
en tiempo real a través de una de las redes inalámbricas
como con un móvil, o algo similar,
y nunca tienen acceso físico a tu auto.
Así es como se ve el equipo para el primer modelo
en el cual tienen acceso al auto.
Toman una computadora y la conectan a la unidad de diagnóstico
de la red interna del coche y hacen todo tipo de tonterías,
como por ejemplo aquí hay una foto del velocímetro
mostrando 225 km por hora cuando el auto está aparcado.
Una vez que han controlado los ordenadores del auto,
puedes hacer cualquier cosa.
Bueno, ahora podrías decir "Oye, eso es absurdo".
Bueno, ¿qué pasaría si se lograra que el auto siempre indicara
que va como a 30 km por hora menos de las que realmente va?
Te podrían poner un montón de multas.
Luego fueron a una pista de aterrizaje abandonada con dos autos,
la víctima y el perseguidor,
y realizaron otros ataques.
Una de las cosas que pudieron hacer desde el auto perseguidor
fue hacer frenar al otro auto,
simplemente hackeando su ordenador.
Fueron capaces de inhibir los frenos.
También fueron capaces de instalar programas maliciosos que no tuvieran efecto
y que no funcionaran hasta que el auto hiciera algo como
ir a más de 30 km por hora.
Los resultados son asombrosos, y cuando compartieron esta charla,
incluso impartiéndola en una conferencia
a un grupo de científicos en seguridad computacional,
todo el mundo estaba boquiabierto.
Fueron capaces de tomar el control de varios de los ordenadores críticos
dentro del auto: el que controla los frenos, las luces,
el motor, el tablero, la radio, etc...
y fueron capaces de hacerlo en vehículos reales de la calle
que compraron, utilizando la señal de radio.
Fueron capaces de comprometer cada
parte del software que controlaba cada una
de la conexiones inalámbricas del auto.
Cada una de ellas fue implementada exitosamente.
¿Cómo se podría robar un auto utilizando este modelo?
Bueno, se podría poner en peligro a través de un desbordamiento de memoria
de la vulnerabilidad en este software, o algo parecido.
Se utiliza el GPS en el auto para localizarlo.
Se quita la llave de las puertas remotamente a través de la computadora
que controla esto, se enciende el motor, se ignora la alarma antirobo,
y listo, ya tienes un vehículo.
La observación fue bastante interesante.
Los autores del estudio tienen un vídeo en el que se muestra
como ellos tomaron control del vehículo y luego encendieron
el micrófono y los parlantes en el auto
mientras lo rastreaban vía GPS en un mapa,
de forma que eso es algo que los conductores
nunca sabrían que está sucediendo.
¿Ya tienen algo de miedo?
Aún tengo algunas más de estas historias interesantes.
Éstas son algunas que recuerdo de una conferencia,
en la que mi mente estaba simplemente asombrada, y yo me decía,
"Tengo que compartir esto con otra gente".
Esta es del laboratorio de Fabian Monrose
en la Universidad de Carolina del Norte, y lo que hicieron fue
algo intuitivo, una vez que uno lo ha visto,
pero sorprendente a la vez.
Ellos grabaron en video a personas en un autobús,
y postprocesaron el vídeo.
Lo que ven aquí, en el número uno es el
reflejo de los anteojos de alguien, del teléfono móvil
en el que está escribiendo.
Ellos escribieron software para estabilizar
—aunque estuvieron dentro del autobús
y quizás con alguien sosteniendo el teléfono en un ángulo específico—
para estabilizar el teléfono, procesarlo y
Uds. deben saber que en su teléfono, cuando ingresan
una contraseña, las teclas resaltan un poco, por lo que fueron capaces
de usar eso para reconstruir lo que la persona estaba escribiendo,
y tenían un modelo de lenguaje para detectar que escribían.
Lo interesante fue, al grabar esto en un autobús,
que fueron capaces de producir exactamente lo que la gente
estaba escribiendo en sus teléfonos,
y luego tuvieron un resultado sorprendente,
su software lo había hecho no solamente para su blanco,
sino para otras personas que accidentalmente
fueron enfocados; fueron capaces de producir
que era lo que ellos habían estado escribiendo, eso fue un
un resultado accidental de lo que su software estaba haciendo.
Les mostraré dos más. Una son las radios P25.
Los P25 son radios utilizados por la policía,
por todo tipo de agencias gubernamentales
y por los soldados en combate para comunicarse,
hay una opción de encriptación en esos teléfonos.
Así es como se ve un teléfono. En realidad no es un teléfono.
Es más como un radio de doble-vía.
Motorola fabrica uno de los más utilizados, y Uds. pueden ver
que son utilizados por el Servicio Secreto y también en combate,
es un estándar bastante, bastante común en EE.UU. y en otros lugares.
Así que una de las preguntas que los investigadores se han hecho es,
¿se podría bloquear este aparato, no?
¿Podrías efectuar un ataque tipo denegación de servicio,
considerando que estos son equipos de primera respuesta?
Entonces, ¿podría una organización terrorista eliminar
la capacidad de la policía y de los bomberos de informar sobre alguna emergencia?
Encontraron que hay un dispositivo GirlTech usado para mandar mensajes de texto
que opera en exactamente la misma frecuencia
que el P25, así es que construyeron lo que llamaron
Mi Primer Bloqueador de Señal. (Risas)
Si ven de cerca este dispositivo,
posee un interruptor para encriptación o texto puro.
Permítanme pasar de diapositiva, y ahora regresaré.
¿Ven la diferencia?
Este es texto puro. Este es encriptado.
Hay un pequeño punto que se despliega en la pantalla,
y también se ve un pequeño giro en el interruptor.
Así es que los investigadores se dijeron, "¿Me pregunto como
es posible que muchas veces conversaciones bien seguras, importantes y delicadas
se dan en estos radios de dos-vías cuando se olvida
encriptar y no se dan cuenta de que no encriptaron?"
Así es que compraron un scanner. Estos son perfectamente legales
y operan en la frecuencia del P25,
lo que hicieron fue saltar en varias frecuencias
y diseñaron un software para escuchar.
Si se encontraban con comunicación encriptada, ellos permanecían
en ese canal y anotaban, que ese era un canal
por medio del cual la gente se comunicaba,
agencias de policía federal,
y se fueron a 20 áreas metropolitanas y escucharon
conversaciones que se daban en esas frecuencias.
Encontraron que en cada área metropolitana,
capturaban más de 20 minutos diarios
de comunicación clara.
Y ¿de qué hablaba la gente?
Bueno, ellos encontraron nombres e información
acerca de informantes confidenciales. Encontraron información
que estaba siendo intervenida telefónicamente,
se discutían varios crímenes,
información delicada.
En su mayoría era información criminal y de policía federal.
Fueron y lo reportaron a la policía federal,
después de dejarlo en el anonimato,
y en este caso la vulnerabilidad es simplemente que la interfaz de usuario
no era lo suficientemente buena. Si se va hablar
de algo realmente seguro y sensible, debe
tenerse completamente claro que esa conversación está encriptada.
Eso se resuelve fácilmente.
Finalmente, el último caso es algo que creo que es algo genial,
y tenía que mostrárselos, probablemente no es algo
por lo que Uds. dejarán de dormir
como los autos o los desfibriladores,
pero está robando tecleadas.
Hemos visto a los teléfonos inteligentes boca abajo.
Cada experto de seguridad quiere hackear un teléfono inteligente,
y tendemos a analizar el puerto USB, el GPS para el rastreo,
la cámara, el micrófono, pero nadie hasta este punto
había observado el acelerómetro.
El acelerómetro es eso que determina
la orientación vertical del teléfono inteligente.
Así que hicieron algo sencillo.
Pusieron un teléfono inteligente junto a un teclado,
y pusieron a la gente a teclear, su meta era
usar las vibraciones que eran generadas al teclear
para medir el cambio en la lectura del acelerómetro
y determinar así lo que la persona había estado escribiendo.
Ahora, al intentar esto en el iPhons 3GS,
esta es una gráfica de las perturbaciones creadas
al escribir, y como pueden observar es bastante difícil
de decir cuándo o qué era lo que alguien estaba escribiendo,
pero en el iPhone 4 con el acelerómetro mejorado,
la misma medición
produjo esta gráfica.
Esto quiere decir que se dio bastante información mientras alguien
estaba tecleando y lo que hicieron entonces fue utilizar
técnicas avanzadas de inteligencia artificial llamadas aprendizaje de máquinas
para tener una fase de entrenamiento,
y fue así que invitaron a varios alumnos universitarios
a que escribieran varias cosas, y para aprender,
y poder tener las herramientas de aprendizaje de máquina
disponibles para aprender lo que la gente escribía
y poder así comparar
con las mediciones del acelerómetro.
Luego vino la fase de ataque, en la que
alguien escribía algo, se desconocía el contenido,
pero utilizando el modelo creado
en la fase de entrenamiento, se determinaba qué era lo que se estaba escribiendo.
Fue algo bastante exitoso. Este es un artículo del USA Today.
Ellos escribieron "La Suprema Corte de Illinois ha ordenado
que Rahm Emanuel es elegible como candidato para la Alcaldía de Chicago".
—vean, esto lo ligué en la última charla—
"y le ordenaron permanecer en la papeleta electoral".
Lo interesante de este sistema es que produjo
"Suprema de Illinois" y entonces no estaba seguro.
El modelo produjo varias opciones,
y esto es lo asombroso de algunas técnicas de I.A.,
las computadoras son buenas en algunas cosas,
los humanos buenos en otras,
tomen lo mejor de ambos y dejen que los humanos resuelvan esto.
No desperdicien los ciclos de computadora.
Un humano no va a pensar que es la voluntad Suprema.
Es la Corte Suprema, ¿verdad?
Y así, juntos lograron reproducir lo que se había escrito
simplemente midiendo el acelerómetro.
¿Por qué importa esto? Bueno, en la plataforma Android,
por ejemplo, los diseñadores tienen un manifiesto
en el que cada dispositivo, el micrófono, etc...
tiene que ser registrado si va a ser utilizado
para que los hackers no puedan controlarlo,
pero nadie controla el acelerómetro.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el punto? Pueden dejar su iPhone
junto al teclado de alguien, y dejar la habitación,
y más tarde recuperar lo que hicieron ellos,
aún sin utilizar el micrófono.
Si alguien es capaz de copiar software malicioso en su iPhone,
también quizás podría acceder a lo que escriban
cuando pongan su iPhone junto a su teclado.
Hay muchos más ataques notables que desgraciadamente
no puedo compartir por falta de tiempo, pero él que quiero mencionar
fue el realizado por un grupo de la Universidad de Michigan
que fue capaz de tomar las máquinas de votación,
a los equipos de grabación directa (DRE) Sequoia AVC Edge que
iban a utilizarse en las elecciones de New Jersey
y que fueron dejados en un pasillo, se les instaló Pac-Man.
Así es que jugaron Pac-Man en ellas.
¿Qué quiere decir todo esto?
Bueno, creo que la sociedad tiende a adoptar la tecnología
rápidamente. Me encanta tener el próximo genial aparato.
Pero es bastante importante, y estos investigadores lo están demostrando,
que los desarrolladores de estas cosas
deben tomar en cuenta desde el inicio los aspectos de seguridad,
y que consideren que aunque tengan soluciones para manejar las amenazas,
los hackers pueden no ser tan amables como
para limitarse a ese modelo de amenazas,
y por ello tienen que pensar fuera de lo normal.
Lo que nosotros podemos hacer, es estar conscientes
de que los dispositivos pueden ser comprometidos,
y que cualquier cosa que tenga software dentro de sí
puede ser vulnerable. Tendrá fallos.
Muchas gracias. (Aplausos)